are you any good at being in the moment
are you any good at you know do you ever
try
because I bring this up for a reason I
have a I am able to really be in the
moment
uh when I'm doing this right now and if
I'm up on stage or doing any kind of
comedic performance I am
100 in the moment and if something goes
wrong I'll go I'll follow that I don't
have any I'm not thinking I don't have
any fear but it's when that's over
I've tried meditation and I cannot do it
I cannot just sit still
um I eat quickly I mean you've seen
sauna it's just a it's a disaster it's
just terrible you're like a wood chipper
yeah
and I eat quickly and I even say
beforehand okay I'm gonna cut my meal in
half I'm gonna take each bite slowly
I'm gonna put my Fork down in between
bites I say all that beforehand and then
they put the food down in front of me
and I like a serial killer black out and
when I wake up everyone's dead oh my god
I've eaten all this problem yeah you're
right you know what this is a good point
man I wish someone else had pointed this
out the plate is still full of food yeah
I haven't touched the food no but I've
murdered and eaten everyone around you
yeah okay yeah this is a different
problem I think I've wandered in too
yeah I don't think that'll hold up in
court it's a weird Alibi
I think yeah I really have a problem
being in the present I murder people at
every dinner
I don't think those words mean what you
think they mean that is so interesting
that you say that because the more I
talk to you the more I see similarities
and just the way we approach life and
our careers I have the same exact thing
when you first ask me do you have
trouble being in the moment I'm like I
don't between like action and cut I
really feel like I'm really there
listening to the other person seeing the
other person responding to them I'm not
thinking about what I did a second ago
or what I'm gonna do a second ago
same thing with stand-up you know when I
used to do a lot of stand up when I was
on stage I truly felt like I was really
existing in that moment you know
um and with acting it took me a little
while to get to that stage but I do feel
for the most part I am there now
um and that's what's exciting about like
acting and stand up for me is as soon as
it's done you're like on this High
because it feels like you jumped out of
a plane and you were truly like there
living in that moment
the rest of my life I do have a problem
with that and it I don't I didn't
realize it tied in with eating food fast
I eat food super fast except dessert I
take tiny bites because I really love it
a lot but Emily's the same way we like
if we go out with another couple it's
embarrassing because our food is done
I'm like literally like in four minutes
our entire food can't say one of the
reasons I didn't recognize Ewan McGregor
is his face was covered in your food you
were eating so quickly that food was
just flying yeah I just saw a beard with
um a lot of shredded beef on it and and
half half two vegetables yeah right you
you cover everyone around right shredded
food who's this guy with ravioli eyes
and why isn't he wearing a kilt
so yeah and I try I do meditate uh
especially when I'm working I meditate
every morning it really really helps me
sort of become present can you tell me
what your technique is because I'm I
mean I don't want to get too personal
but what I I have tried and tried and
tried and I don't know how to do it well
my mind was you know they say it's
whatever the mind is like a thousand
monkeys mine all need Adderall each each
monkey needs uh now it's the opposite
I've never heard that term is that maybe
just your therapist said that this is
the problem with your mind is you're
making up these terms you know how
everyone's mind is a thousand Crazy
Monkeys yeah no I don't know that you
know how when you go to eat quickly you
black out and you wake up and everyone's
dead yeah so far I'm an up you know what
I love I'm an observational comic those
observations no one can relate to right
you literally think you have a thousand
monkeys inside your head I really do oh
see this is a problem yeah yeah a
thousand you know sometimes uh when
you're out and you're buying a sort of a
1920s diving suit you know the kind with
the brass helmet sure and you're eating
custard you know we've all been yeah
right oh yeah and you walk in and then
there's a robot but yeah my observations
are no one's relating to anything I'm
saying I apologize I think the issue
with with uh meditating for me that then
I think I was able to solve was uh
taking the pressure off of doing it
right even like a bad meditation session
makes me feel better when it's done I
only do it for 10 minutes I don't do it
longer than that it you know it is hard
to sit still for that long but I just
took the pressure off of trying to be
good at it and it really helps you just
kind of have to sit there quietly and if
your mind is going somewhere just try
and nudge it back do nothing try and
feel your body try and feel the ground
beneath your feet or the cushion under
your butt you know it really helps it
happens sometimes with acting like I'll
be doing a scene and I'm like not
feeling
like it's going right it happened on
Chippendales and I was like I just was
like this is gonna sound so lame
wasn't feeling in the scene and I was
like I'm gonna take 10 seconds and just
really touch this table and as soon as I
touched the table and really felt it
it all opened up and suddenly I was like
present in the scene again so I think
for me the hardest thing is first
realizing when I'm not in the moment
because that can be hard to know like oh
I'm like thinking about stuff outside of
myself right now